this is fusion cuisine a story about
Stephen getting in trouble with another
family because the family doesn't like
the fact he has more than one mommy um
Wow
that's essentially what it is I don't
know was I the only one that I got that
vibe I me it's like I said that nuclear
family although she did say to adults so
maybe it's like they don't care if it's
like you know a gay cowboy or whatever I
don't yeah I'm not even sure it had to
be a nuclear family I just think they
wanted to make sure Stephen had a parrot
hmm which to be fair I mean again kind
of looking over how they do this it's
like can't win Jew - I still don't
entirely get this I would I believe in
the Pippi Longstocking way I'm wrong um
so yeah so they fuse together which is
neat to see it's neat to see all three
le mama get the CL through Alexandra I
don't know why they thought that would
work but it's like how it sort of starts
to work like they still like you know
they would rather just not be rude and
call attention to the obvious elephant
in the room rather than say what the
hell are you um I like I like them try
this Cape at the end like just take a
bus out of there which let's be I
haven't want to do that during some
awkward get together sometimes Oh God
and then seeing them and then seeing the
fusion come in and grab them and punish
them it's a V that was very funny um and
yeah seems to be that there definitely
seems to be like a very partial control
particularly between a county and a
mother you know they having to call our
man and stuff like that like constantly
you know uh it's definitely a little
awkward but um again they sort of saw
good parenting tip of if it was no TV
for a thousand years um and no she mean
we wouldn't starve you just no TV for a
thousand here so um you know so there's
a compromise I like that like how it
both sides hurricane don't count for my
other idea I guess really the steep
inside to really come to that much but
compromise the more I think about it
although they try they try to fuse
together and
um so yeah uh I thought was fine like I
said so which one of them would you have
taken what would I have taken uh I was
gonna say guarded until that
hilarious moment where she panicked and
I I think I almost had to buy blanket
shorts oh no the bleeding oh no they did
sorry I panicked I mean just like
perfect up out of nowhere deadpan
perfect delivery uh and you can see her
you know she's always so smooth and so
cool but you can see her just not being
good at that situation just I would have
taken pearl I think when he came around
a pearl I'm like yeah that's where I
make samosa chicas said something but
everything could make him a excuse of
why she couldn't eat dinner or something
uh I may be tough come up with one I'm
sure there's something way more says
enthusiam altogether but I wanna bet his
bunny um but uh ya know I I thought this
was uh pre fighting I liked this episode
yeah um very last one yes say the least
um I'm curious if a good dive more into
like Connie's relationship with her
parents cuz yeah there's definitely her
still wearing the glasses and stuff like
she really is like it really seems like
she's ashamed to sort of reveal it would
do shooting stuff uh whatnot but again
it's clearly motivated by the fear of
marriage uh but you got all the people I
always like oh what's this gold
companies based on mystery no it's not
there could be just happy peppy stuff no
misery at all stop we're OK garnet said
it's all based on fear which is he did
of misery that made me laugh hard yeah I
be home Jesus Christ oh yeah I mean it's
just all these feels like no no and then
they try to list these examples I'm
always like here's how it connects to
fear all right here's how it connects to
misery that connects the misery that
connects I mean it all connects
nobody's yeah nobody's given me an
example yet somebody tried to say
wordplay like puns and I'm like you only
wit puns out when you want to make
people groan that's a misery well no on
topic it's a mockery of language you
know if somebody's pride has to be
threatened in order for comedy to be to
work um you know that that is comedy
that that's how it works
but yeah because all the people just
like you oh you're so gone I have no
examples but you're wrong it's like
garnet said it okay so but but
but like what about like something that
is happy peppy like Family Circus Family
Circus isn't funny it never has been
funny um I don't get Family Circus but
even if even if you do it's like oh only
we're little only like blah blah it's
like still Kim looking for a day
still misery so problem only 75 year old
women you know coming home from church
get Family Circus like it's always you
always go to some crazy old church
lady's house there's always a Family
Circus cartoon on the fridge that is the
audience evil I was like a toddler I'm
just looking at this like white why does
this exist yeah I don't care the crazy
church lady that Dana Carvey played on
SNL she would have family on it yeah
that is the intended audience
um but anywho a good episode good seeing
um good knowing that Connie and Stephen
are still uh still together I usually
don't like these you know I never like
this set up for these oh no we have to
have this dinner get together and one
family has this issue another as this is
yeah but this has made funny by the fact
that they combined three people into a
giant superwoman no here's the thing
I never like the setup but like eighty
percent of the time it usually has a
funny delivery you know the birdcage is
hilarious uh you know I mean that movie
cracks me up and it's one that was wrap
on something you would see the crazy
church ladies sort of probably not you
know a la Fawlty Towers it's like you
hear all this build-up in this
exposition it's like okay but then when
you get to it it's like yeah it was
worth it was funny uh and it is I mean
it's great seeing these characters work
off each other and you know that tried
to do this for Stephen as well it's very
heartfelt and stuff so uh no I thought
was a good episode that was funny
I get cool design on the the fusion of
them and uh yeah can't think of too much
else I think you got no yep pretty much
covered it yeah Family Circus isn't
funny yeah if there's anything we really
need to
take the missus that Family Circus isn't
funny yeah so oh and don't lie about
friends family or lot else maybe they'll
punish you with family search yes
thousand years Family Circus the hell oh
god oh hey I guess all comedy you space
them visit there you go I'm miserable
now yeah I'm gonna be some family circus
to feel better now don't do it it's
awful